[Musique]
c'est un beau move elle dans la vie une
grande page de l'histoire économique de
châteauroux s'est déroulée la dédié aux
manufactures de draps le parc balzan
s'étend sur 49 hectares le long de la
rue il renferme des bâtiments témoin de
la splendeur passée d'une famille les
balises auxquelles son histoire est
intimement liés mais il est aussi depuis
20 ans un quartier en forte mutation qui
abrite les qu'au campus de châteauroux
[Musique]
franchissant les grilles du parc celle
qui menait ou de ça tout le château
rivière et le château tour aujourd'hui
réhabilité en logements de standing pour
y retrouver jean pierre sueur aux
historiens qui nous les présente
il a toujours été d que la manufacture a
été construite la demeure des directeurs
ou des propriétaires il était séparé de
la manufacture par un mur et prolongée
par un grand parc à la française
d'abord qui sera ensuite transformé en
parc al anglaise par la famille galland
qui donne en gros le parc actuel avec
sept tours du 15e siècle c'est le seul
restes d'un ancien château qui fut
démolie il était d'ailleurs en voie
d'abandon pour construire la manufacture
mais on a voulu garder ce symbole d'une
période ancienne
alors nous avons dernier derrière nous
l'ancienne aile des teinturiers de la
manufacture qui va devenir la propriété
des deux fils de pierre balland
directeur de l'entreprise
auguste balzan et charl van zant
les deux fils friands de style
néogothique feront adjoindre un
embellissement au bâtiment initial qui
auparavant ressembler à celui qui lui
fait face
elle des tisserands en très mauvais état
il porte sur son fronton une date
1752 celle de la construction de la
manufacture royale que charles balzan et
son épouse rachèteront un siècle plus
tard quand il arrive
la situation de la manufacture a bien
changé depuis le départ puisque la
première elle dit des tisserands a été
vendue en 1818 à l'armée qui a fait
construire un bâtiment supplémentaire
qui est dans l'esprit de la manufacture
mais plus grand père valaisan s'est
alors rendu compte mais là c'est un très
mauvais épisode de sa vie que son
acquisition allait le ruiner parce que
la manufacture de châteauroux compte
tenu de l'évolution des techniques de
l'époque devenu obsolète ses fils vont
le persuader de construire il en avait
les moyens financiers le soutien
bancaire une usine toute neuve qui sera
la magnifique projet que réalisera
l'architecte alfred d'auvergne
la maquette de la manufacture imaginé
par alfred d'auvergne longtemps conservé
dans le bureau directorial montre la
magnificence du projet richard balzan il
y aurait dépensé trois millions de
francs à rapprocher des mille francs de
salaire annuel des ouvriers qui
travaillaient alors les archives
municipales ont aussi des témoignages
photographiques des ateliers et des
machines de l'époque donc là c'est le
seul premier album ce les photos les les
plus anciennes que l'on à la manufacture
balzan avec un reportage photo qui a été
fait par placide verre d'eau un
photographe importante châteauroux qui a
été notamment le dernier portraitiste de
george sand et là on voit que l'état des
machines est presque neuf on voit toute
une machinerie en très bon état
ce sont des clichés d'à peu près on est
20 en 1883
donc on a à peu près une vingtaine
d'années après l'ouverture de de la
manufacture et on a un autre reportage
photo qui a été réalisé pour les 50 ans
de l'entreprise en 1910 par un autre
photographe donc jules d'orsan
oula le parti pris du photographe est de
montrer d'abord une vue générale du site
de l'entreprise et de décliner son
reportage pour expliquer depuis
l'arrivée d'hélène tout le processus de
fabrication du drap ateliers par atelier
au plus fort de la production on était à
mille cinq cents personnes
donc c'est quand même une des grandes
manufactures de france la plus moderne
sans doute oui oui en 1860 lorsque ont
créé cette entreprise nouvelle tournée
dans ce qu'il ya de mieux à l'époque
il aura fallu à peine plus d'un siècle
pour que l' usine flambant neuve
devienne à son tour obsolètes les
bâtiments s'adaptant mal aux
modifications des stratégies
industrielles une nouvelle usine est
construite à la campagne sonnant le glas
de l'histoire industrielle du site qui
vit la naissance du fameux bleu horizon
le drap utilisé par les armées
françaises pendant la grande guerre
pendant près de 30 ans le site restera
en déshérence vendu à la ville de
châteauroux en 1988 le parc ses
dépendances
les châteaux les ateliers de part et
d'autre du bâtiment de l'horloge vont
devoir trouver de nouvelles utilisations
[Musique]
en 2003 le désamiantage et la
destruction de la cheminée emblématique
du site symbolise le début de la
renaissance il faudra encore attendre
quatre ans pour que la première
construction neuve sortent de terre le
centre d'études supérieures antenne de
l'université d'orléans s'installe dans
ses locaux avec succès dans l'ensemble
le bilan est plutôt positif le fait
d'avoir des locaux qui sont relativement
neuf est quand même un atout en terme de
présentation on ne sait aussi un atout
en termes d'image que l'on peut
transmettre et on voit que le nombre
d'étudiants augmente sans cesse alors
pas depuis 2007 puisqu'il ya eu un petit
creux mais depuis cinq six ans le nombre
est en augmentation assez importante
puisqu'on a pratiquement doublé le
nombre de jeunes sur place aujourd'hui
500 étudiants français et 140 chinois
fréquentent le lieu qui a pratiquement
atteint le maximum de sa capacité
d'accueil
premier établissement de l'éco campus le
cs voit quatre ans plus tard sortir de
terre en lieu et place d'une partie des
anciens bâtiments restaurés et intégrer
une nouvelle école d'ingénieurs voulues
par la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie nous avions donc ce manque
d'offre et l'idée dès 2002 et venue avec
le bureau de la chambre de commerce
qu'il fallait que nous recherchions des
partenariats afin de créer une école
d'ingénieurs mais notre demande très
spécifiques
nous voulions une école d'ingénieurs par
apprentissage
nous avons regroupé toutes les
formations supérieures que nous avions à
la chambre de commerce
nous sommes le cfaa interconsulaire le
plus important dans la région centre val
de loire
nous avons créé les qu'au campus l'écho
campus qui est en fait un outil de
communication qui regroupe douze
établissements
nous offrons 47 diplôme et nous avons
2300 étudiants
donc c'était qu'au campus permet à tous
les établissements du département de
l'indre qui font de la formation
supérieure
de venir nous retrouver parce qu'on voit
bien que lorsque nous sommes regroupés
nous avons la lisibilité et nous pouvons
parler tous d'une même voix fédérer et
mutualiser autour de projets pour
pallier la petitesse du territoire est
devenu une seconde nature sur l'éco
campus nous voulons équiper tous les
établissements sur l'éco campus de
visioconférence immersive c'est une
nouvelle technologie qui existe
les collectivités me font confiance sur
ce projet nous avons déjà
un cahier des charges qui se dessine et
nous voulons absolument que cette
fracture territoriale qui existent
soient comblés par le numérique en tout
cas nous avons beaucoup d'espoir sur ce
numérique les locaux de la cheville
accueille depuis trois ans le fab lab
baptisé berry l'ap 36 une structure
ouverte à tous
l'association compte 90 membres et 6
femmes managers
on a évidemment les étudiants qui ont
qui pratique et met en pratique leurs
connaissances dans cette dans cet
atelier on a des gens qui viennent le
soir pour développer des pièces pour
comprendre comment marchent les
imprimantes 3d
la fonction du numérique dans ces
domaines là on va progresser encore dans
le niveau d'équipement de cette
association en ouvrant un thé cloud avec
des machines beaucoup plus importantes
qui vont permettre de faire des pièces
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus grande et
qui permettent à des entreprises de
venir tester leurs produits
donc on s'inscrit dans lé dans les
programmes de l' usine du futur et des
programmes d'innovation que l'on met en
place avec le conseil régional sentent
mal de l'eau dans les prochaines années
le rôle de pôle d'enseignement de
formation et de développement du
numérique du barc balzan
devrait encore s'accentuer nouvelle
réalisation qui débute la cité du
numérique qui permettra de redonner au
bâtiment de l'horloge une seconde vie
l'objectif de l'opération
c'est d'installer ici sur les campus
tout un tas d'activités d'équipements
qui viennent compléter le centre de
formation le campus de la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie le centre
d'études supérieures de l'université
d'orléans avec des activités annexes
donc un centre aquatique balsa neo est
ici derrière moi dans le bâtiment qu'on
appelle le pavillon de l'horloge une
cité du numérique qui accueillera une
pépinière d'entreprise développée sous
le label village maïtia par le crédit
agricole et un amphithéâtre un
auditorium de 400 places qui lui servira
l'ensemble des sites et des
établissements d'enseignement de
l'époque en plus livraison prévue fin
2010 9 premier trimestre 2020 mais les
ambitions pour la dynamisation du parc
ballan ne s'arrête pas là d'autres
réalisations vont s'enchaîner au cours
des prochaines années que nous aurons
fini la réalisation de la cité du
numérique nous aurons fait à peu près
les deux tiers de lusine ballon il nous
restera un tiers dans lequel
s'installera après 2020 l'école
d'infirmières l'ifsi institut de
formation aux soins infirmiers plus de
maison de m sur lesquels nous cherchons
une vocation est plutôt un porteur de
projet et où nous verrions bien une
activité dans le domaine de l'hôtellerie
et de la restauration
voilà plutôt haut de gamme dans un
environnement qui s'y prêtent il aura
fallu aux municipalités qui se sont
succédé une réelle volonté de
transformer le quartier balzan pour le
faire entrer de plain pied dans le 21e
siècle il ya déjà trente ans que la
ville de châteauroux est propriétaire de
ce site
les projets ont mis du temps à arriver
mais les opérations étaient lourdes il
fallait déjà des amiantés mettre en
sécurité
trouvez la vocation investir de l'argent
beaucoup d'argent trouver des aides
rien que l'école d'ingénieurs a coûté
près de 15 millions d'euros
la cité du numérique va quitter va
coûter aux environs de
six millions et demi d'euros et chaque
fois c'est beaucoup de travail en amont
beaucoup de fond a mobilisé aujourd'hui
on estime encore une dizaine d'années le
temps nécessaire pour qu'on puisse
réhabiliter l'ensemble du cycle au cours
des prochains mois un nouvel équipement
prise en charge par la communauté
d'agglomération et dans la construction
va débuter prochainement devrait
apporter une nouvelle notoriété au lieu
balsa néo le centre aquatique va en
effet s'installer à proximité du campus
l'éco-quartier voulu et résolument
tournée vers la jeunesse et l'entreprise
mes loisirs et détente font aussi partie
de l'adn du lieu d'ici visiteurs
étudiants habitant du quartier et
promeneurs s'y côtoient chacun y trouve
sa place et ce n'est pas le moindre
mérite de cette vaste réhabilitation